grogu AKA baby Yoda is a 50 year old
toddler which may seem totally alien but
some animals on Earth aged that slowly
too take Greenland sharks they don't
reach maturity until they're over a
century old and live hundreds of years
so why are some species so slow aging
and long-lived While others last only a
few years in general animals that can't
protect themselves live fast and die
young mice for instance are pretty
likely to starve or get eaten so there's
a lot of evolutionary pressure on mice
to grow up and start having babies fast
but there's almost no pressure on them
to evolve long lasting bodies other
animals have the advantage of being able
to fly or being big or having big brains
and those species may be less likely to
die in the jaws of a predator as a
result those animals aren't pressured to
rush the reproduction they grow up more
slowly and have babies over a longer
period of time which can increase the
odds that their offspring survive that's
why some bats can live 30 years
elephants can live 60 years and big
brained primates like people or bonobos
live much longer than is expected for a
mammal of their size with Yoda being a
wise Jedi Master big brains could be the
secret to the longevity of his and grogu
species too